but third you need if even if you had
those two things you need courage to
face what might be possible for you
as I have worked with people over the
years it's become very evident to me
that if one is flagging and courage you
will go to denial because it's too
overwhelming but a lot of folks have a
tremendous difficulty in having courage
and I thought and I thought have thought
about this a long time trying to figure
out why don't people have courage and
then it began to be more and more clear
to me that there's another element you
have to have energy or you will not have
courage and so if you don't have energy
and therefore you don't have courage you
won't be able to face either what's
possible for you and you certainly won't
be able to face what's wrong now how
does one have energy here I agree with
the great Paul Tillich I think you have
you get energy through faith now faith I
also used I use this the way that
Tillich used it so you sort of either
have it or you don't
it doesn't mean you believe something it
doesn't mean you feel a certain way
it doesn't even mean
you will a certain thing faith means
that in fact discernibly you're hooked
up to something that pulls you together
that has juice you're hooked up to
something we can say this that mediates
juice I like to say so there's a kind of
a phenomenological thing about faith
that is to say if you see everyone has
some faith or they would be dead all of
their systems would be fragmented and
and quiet faith is that phenomenon of
yourself being pulled together there is
something pulling you together pulling
you together against the forces that
would try to destroy you and so it pulls
you together and enables you to stand
into your life so it's not a question of
do you have faith by the virtue of the
fact that you're sitting here you have
faith the issue is how powerful is this
if I really look carefully at myself is
what I'm hooked up to am I getting
enough juice through this pulling me
pulling me into integration that I can
resist the fragmenting forces that are
coming at me from without and within so
all of us it
particular time are somewhere on a kind
of a continuum you will notice that some
days you actually have more faith than
others and it's something you just
simply can look at it am I am I being
pulled together so that I can step into
my life with courage and face my
possibilities and face those things
which are trying to kill me you know
does that make sense
okay and one of the things to do when
you know I always do when I'm teaching
people about you know spiritual
direction or spiritual leadership as I
say what you do with with anyone is you
simply try to look and see what the
state of faith in this person is and
then you look at what their faith is in
or in other words you could put it this
way what is mediating their faith
because they may think their religion is
religion a and they may have very hard
very PI passionate commitment to this
dogma of this religion but if you look
close at them they may be hooked up and
be connected to the juice through a
person it may be coming in through a
person it may be coming in through an
image of themselves but you folks that
are really wonderful
you know your faith can actually be in
an image of yourself and the interesting
thing is that if you're getting the
juice that's pulling you together and
enabling you to stand against the
destructive forces in your life it is
working somewhat and I started out by
saying there's a way in which all faiths
are idolatrous to some degree so even
idolatrous face our faiths and because
they mediate power they mediate juice
that pulls a person together to some
degree or the other so as you're looking
at yourself from the spiritual issue you
can ask yourself well how how is my
faith and you know am I am i accessing
energy that's pulling me together so I
can step into my life resist the forces
of destruction that are trying to
destroy me
what is mediating it to me where am i
connecting with it maybe a woman you
know maybe a career fantasy follow me
but if you look closely there is there
is some place where you're hooked in
where you're plugged in I like to say
you're plugged in some way see it's very
important to look at that because a
faith can be in something that is really
going to disappoint you later
yeah and and so but but the fifth thing
is is faith the element of faith because
if you have no faith even idolatrous
faith it's you can say like this
idolatrous faith is better than no pay
at all see because without adult without
faith I mean it you know then you're in
real danger of of just having your
despair kill you one of the things we
all struggle with is despair and